mais d'abord cette interrogation et vous
que feriez-vous avec un million d'euros
c'est la question que doit se poser
actuellement une chambre brésienne le 3
février dernier à la remporté un million
d'euros à l'Euro Millions en validant
son billet au bar tabac de l'hôtel de
ville de Chambray-lès-Tours un coup de
chance également pour les patrons du
commerce qui s'attendent à une hausse de
sa fréquentation Faustine Luneau et la
Turquie si vous étiez millionnaire du
jour au lendemain qu'est-ce que vous
feriez je ferai plaisir à mes
petits-enfants mes enfants vous n'auriez
petite fille comme tout le monde une
belle maison belle voiture des voyages
si c'est moi la prochaine fois je pense
que peut-être que je rachèterai des
trimestres de retraite étant donné que
voilà c'est tout à fait d'actualité
peut-être que je vous en ferai pas
profiter d'une partie parce que c'est
sûr que ça peut être trop long un rêve
devenu réalité pour une cliente de ce
bar tabac de Chambray-lès-Tours après
avoir acheté un code my million à ce
comptoir le Russe gagnante a été tiré au
sort le 3 février dernier et a remporté
un million d'euros du jamais vu pour le
patron installé dans la commune depuis
10 ans les gains de ses clients
n'avaient jamais dépassé quelques
dizaines de milliers d'euros un très
gros lot on peut qualifier ça de très
gros lots depuis que je suis ici et je
suis content pour eux vraiment je suis
content que ça soit fait chez nous quoi
car la chance de la gagnante pourrait
aussi avoir un impact positif sur ses
ventes de tickets et grille de loterie
on a toujours une part de joueurs un peu
superstitieux qui qui croit que dans
certains points de vente on gagne plus
qu'ailleurs les bons ou les affiches
comme vous avez là-haut attire et les
gens ont les joueurs ont tendance à
regarder ce qui ce qui se gagnent ici
lorsque de très gros gains sont en jeu
l'établissement enregistre 15 à 20% de
mise en plus que pour les autres tirages
des centaines de millions d'euros qui
attirent les joueurs mais gagner une
telle somme du jour au lendemain n'est
pas anodin la Française des jeux propose
donc au gagnant une série d'ateliers
pour les préparer à leur nouvelle vie ce
sont des ateliers qui ont trait à la
gestion patrimoniale mal à la gestion
notariale à l'accompagnement du
changement et puis aussi des ateliers
sur sur des engagements forts comme la
philanthropie ou la transition
écologique notre nouvelle millionnaire à
retirer ses gains elle fait partie des
25 français parmi 100 euros à avoir
gagné cette somme au tirage exceptionnel
du 3 février